Tardes y encantado de conocerte y ponerle
cara a tu solicitud de información.
Como sabes, mi nombre es Manuel Martínez.
Yo soy asesor académico en o b s Business
School Partner,
académico de la Universidad de Barcelona
y vamos a tener una breve sesión
informativa sobre 1 de nuestros programas,
que es nuestro máster en neuromarketing y
comportamiento del consumidor.
Corrígeme si recuerdo mal,
pero tienes empresa propia.
Y además sí que recuerdo que en la
conversación que tuvimos ya hace una
semana.
Me comentabas que habías ganado un un
premio hacía poquito sobre una estrategia
nueva de comportamiento del consumidor
que llevas 13 años implementando 13 o 14
años implementando estrategias de
neuromarketing,
pero que lo que sí que notas es que vas
un poco de manera autodidacta, es decir,
vas cogiendo cosas o aprendiendo cosas
que las vas poniendo en marcha y te van
funcionando un un único matiz. Todo,
todo es así excepto no,
no es que llegara a ganar un premio.
Ganamos un proyecto con el Ministro de la
Industria.
Para llevar a cabo con con un cluster que
se llama Ambit.
Es un cluster que está muy focalizado en
temas de arquitectura y neuro
arquitectura.
Y lo lo ganamos el año pasado
conjuntamente con la escuela, con el CET,
con la Escuela de Turismo de Barcelona.
En este caso se cogieron dos estudios,
se se hicieron dos estudios por separado.
El mío era mucho más de.
De impacto de consumidor en mis tiendas.
Yo tengo una cadena de pastelerías sin
gluten,
5 tiendas en Barcelona en estos momentos,
el resto están todas repartidas por
España. ¿Y bueno,
lo que veníamos a analizar no porque
siempre ha sido, pues mi hobby,
mi obsesión y me encanta la neurociencia,
no? Pues el.
¿Cómo se comporta el consumidor en los
diferentes procesos?
No como entonces medíamos a través de de
unas cámaras que cada que le colocamos en
en diferentes puntos de las tiendas.
¿Medimos las emociones, EH?
Fundamentalmente.
Y también medimos la capacidad de
reconocimiento de marca desde de largas
distancias. No es decir,
la la percepción emocional,
no a través de estas cámaras.
¿De una persona que estaba,
o sea a 500 600 m la podríamos captar, no?
Con lo cual de ahí sacamos los resultados
superinteresantes desde situaciones de
estrés que se crean en el momento de la
compra, como una persona mirando,
pues la vitrina,
pues podía mostrar más felicidad,
menos felicidad. No,
no fuimos a 1 segundo punto que es.
Exactamente a qué producto, a qué color,
a qué posición.
Eso lo podría hacer con la empresa con la
que llevamos a cabo.
¿Este proyecto se llama Goli,
está en es una empresa que está en Málaga
y bueno, bueno, fue muy interesante no?
Porque nos permitió realmente hacer una
redistribución arquitectónica del de
tienda. No tuvimos que hacer movimientos,
mobiliario en.
¿En en en decoración, interiorismo?
¿Pues para mejorar el confort no?
Y la experiencia del consumidor.
Entonces eso ha sido espectacular,
no podemos hablar súper súper interesante.
¿Te iba a preguntar la medición de es que
yo soy también un fanático de la
neurociencia? Sí, me sí, me encanta.
Además me etiquetaron hace muy poquito
como neurodivergente,
que es como la nueva tendencia esta que
hay dentro de cerebros configurados desde
otro lugar.
¿Yo llevo meses que prácticamente solo
Leo sobre este tipo de cosas y la lectura
de emociones la hicisteis a través de lo
que era gestualidad, o sea,
gestualidad de cara o o gestualidad
corporal también en principio es de cara,
en principio cara, es decir,
es la la la medida de emociones por cara,
EH?
Fundamentalmente son unas cámaras que por
inteligencia artificial, bueno,
pues te te te captan, te captan todo.
Bueno, era la verdad,
es que era muy interesante,
no de cómo en una.
¿Cómo entrando en la tienda?
Pues una persona podía estar
transformando sus emociones,
no según iba percibiendo el producto o la
recepción de un servicio, por ejemplo.
¿Pues claro,
yo pongo ya máquinas no olfativas en las
tiendas,
trabajo en una empresa de de aromas,
la música,
el color de las tiendas que son,
en mi caso todas son diferentes, no?
Entonces obtuvimos pues información,
ya te digo, pues interesante desde.
Desde que el consumidor a larga distancia
esos 500 600 M. ¿No, no, no,
no entendiera que es shock,
que es que es mi marca,
no que que eso ni es bueno ni es malo, EH?
Únicamente no lo entendía.
Pusimos luego vinilos explicando,
pues si vendemos cookies sin gluten lo
que sea es igual. No, no, no.
Al final el resumen del del del estudio
fue que la potencia de mi marca.
Está en la vitrina, está en la manera.
¿Cómo exponemos lo que exponemos y cuando
lo exponemos,
no mucho más que el que en el
Interiorismo, Eh? ¿Es decir,
que que el día de mañana,
pues si no me quiero gastar tanto dinero
en Interioristas, pues no va a pasar nada,
EH? Porque la fuerza de mi marca,
considerando que tengo 30 tiendas, EH,
30 tiendas son todas las tiendas son
diferentes,
tú vas a entrar en una tienda mía y.
¿YY percibes el alma de marca por, por,
por por lo cómo lo exponemos y lo que
vendemos? Pues es súper interesante. YYY.
Fíjate que no todo El Mundo se toma la
molestia de realizar estudios así con su
marca.
Más bien normalmente van a lo fácil.
A crea un estilo,
todas son iguales para que sea
reconocible.
No, yo no, yo desde hace 13 años. Bueno,
yo soy una persona de la del NEUROMARQUE,
no pasa.
Hace 13 años ni tenía la capacidad ni la
tengo ahora no de a nivel de inversión,
pues para ponerte las gafas para hacer
lecturas de cerebro,
no de de medir los impulsos del cerebro,
ni ni ni.
Ni dónde mira el el ojo del consumidor.
¿Yo lo fui haciendo a través de de libros
de y prueba error, EH? ¿Es decir,
si yo me leía un libro que siempre digo
yo tengo mi Biblia, no?
En el libro de Martín Lynnstrong,
que se llama Biology Biology,
para mí es mi Biblia,
que me la sigo leyendo muchas veces.
¿Pues bueno,
fue el libro que me inspiró y gracias a
ese libro yo me unté en mi concepto, vale,
o sea, fue así, no?
Iba siguiendo las pautas hasta dar con lo
que hoy es mi marca, no,
luego lo lo complementé con con otros
estudios, con bibliografía,
vídeos con potentes internacionales YY
bueno y chlo,
que es el resultado de de la
neuromarketing,
no del neuromarke de la ciencia.
¿Y sigo interesada en esto,
sigo comprando libros, sigo estudiando,
tengo amigos que son ponentes,
profesores de neuromarketing,
neurociencia y el otro día al ver el el
el máster vuestro, no? Pues.
¿Incluso doy clases de neuromarketing sin
ser profesor titulado, No,
pero también doy charlas gracias a a los
estudios que he hecho en mi en mis 13
años, no,
pero en mis tiendas entonces siempre es
un tema de aprendizaje,
no es lo que me motiva y estar al día y
ver si hay algo que de manera docente
pues pueda encajarme y complementarme, no?
¿Pero es como si me comprara un libro, Eh,
o sea,
el interés mío por vosotros de verdad,
como si me comprara un libro,
pues lo tengo, no? ¿Pues ya semanal,
no en en clase, claro, yo escuchándote,
Fernando, yo quería preguntarte,
tú has llegado a ver nuestra página web,
el programa nos conoces? No lo pude ver,
no pude descargarlo, no sé, no, no,
no lo tuve fácil, entonces por eso dije,
bueno, me llamáis, me lo explicáis,
me lo quitó el.
El tema y si encaja bien, si me va por no,
no, no, no lo pude, no lo pude descargar,
la verdad. Pues mira,
y a nosotros nos conocías porque entiendo
que a la Universidad de Barcelona sí, sí,
a la Universidad de Barcelona sí,
y a mí me llegó esto,
yo creo que por Instagram,
porque al final estoy muy conectado con
con las redes y creo que fue publicidad
por Instagram. Volaría.
Pues sí, no.
En cualquier en el momento que empiezas a
hacer búsquedas es que te llega cual te
llega todo relacionado a además,
ahora es de una manera,
creo que mucho menos útil de lo que lo
era antes.
A mí al menos me lo parece a mí.
Yo basta que haga una búsqueda de de una
cosa concreta y de golpe esa semana es
todo.
Todo, todo, todo eso. Yes,
no sé si bueno lo lo lee,
lo lo yo creo que hasta los teléfonos
tienen una manera de percibir ya lo que
estamos mirando y no y lo mires en las de
segundo ya te traen,
te traen la información y por y por la
escucha no, pero bueno, mira,
yo yo hice no,
yo creo que además deben de tenerlo
seguro.
Hice una búsqueda hace muy poquito en en
inteligencia artificial para irme de
viaje.
Pensando que destino me podría ir mejor
teniendo en cuenta que me voy en
diciembre,
que es todo diciembre lo que busco tal
pues a o sea, a partir de esa noche, toda,
toda toda la información, o sea,
toda la publicidad que me llegaba era
referente a vuelos,
hoteles y todo muy canalizado hacia los
lugares donde he decidido que me voy a ir.
O sea que YY pensaba digo es que ya está
la inteligencia artificial tiene una
manera de.
¿Compartir información tuya?
No sé muy bien,
pero pero pero al final y todo es para mí.
¿Es neurociencia, EH? Quiero decir,
es cada teléfono. O sea,
nos llega la información porque le
ponemos interés a cosas que nosotros ni
sabemos en que no.
Entonces de pronto nos aparecen y nos la
venden, no de la mejor manera.
Entonces, bueno,
todo va ligado y todo esto me interesa.
Y por primero por dos cosas,
una por por mi empresa,
por beneficio de mi empresa y otra por
porque me encanta. Es una,
es un campo que me encanta,
el de la neurociencia,
el neuromarketing me encanta,
me encanta y bueno,
y quiero estar al día a a pesar de que lo
estoy, Eh, ya te digo, Eh,
que estoy en contacto con profesores de
que escriben libros de Neuromarketing y
todo, pero bueno, siempre.
Es estar ahí. Y al ver vuestro,
al ver vuestro vuestra información,
no vuestra publicidad, dije, hombre,
no hay tanta gente que empiece a
publicitar másters o cursos de esta,
no de esta rama. Pues mira,
yo te voy a compartir pantalla y creo que
lo primero que te tengo que enseñar a TI
es el programa,
porque yo creo que ahí es donde vamos a
ver con el plan de estudios.
Si realmente tú crees que te puede
funcionar o no, si vemos que sí,
luego te presentaré. ¿Quiénes somos?
Nuestra vinculación con la Universidad de
Barcelona,
ya que ofrecemos doble titulación
nosotros y la VY además la de la UB no
hace referencia a que el programa sea en
online o en presencial. Es decir,
es la titulación de máster de la
Universidad de Barcelona con el
reconocimiento que tiene a día de hoy
mejor Universidad del mundo en lengua
española. Bueno, todo esto,
pero yo creo que el programa es lo que en
un perfil como el tuyo va a ser
determinante para que tú puedas valorar.
Si realmente es lo que vas buscando,
lo que te voy a enseñar es nuestra página
web, Fernando.
Con esto te quiero decir que es
información de libre acceso para todo El
Mundo.
Nuestro máster en neuromarketing y
comportamiento consumidor está
considerado por el ranking dead universal,
que es un ranking internacional e
independiente y que solo valora programas
tanto grados universitarios como másteres
entre los 5 mejores en español de su
categoría.
Trabaja de entrada con cuatro objetivos
clave, el comportamiento del consumidor,
las herramientas de Neuromarketing,
el análisis neurológico y, por último,
cómo llevarlo a estrategias de marketing.
Se encuentra dentro del marco europeo de
la educación superior y esto nos da de
entrada como dos datos técnicos
importantes.
El primero de ellos tener una
equivalencia real de 60 créditos lectivos.
Y esto es lo que nos faculta tanto a
nosotros o b s Business School como la
Universidad de Barcelona de poderlo
titular como Máster.
El segundo dato importante es la duración,
hablamos de una duración de 12 meses.
En concreto,
este programa da comienzo ahora a
principios de octubre,
que es nuestro calendario habitual de
másteres.
Esos 12 meses se organizan en torno a 10
unidades temáticas.
Cada unidad temática tiene un desarrollo
temporal de un mes y se vertebran en
estos 3 grandes bloques,
fundamentos para el neuromarketing,
aplicaciones del Neuromarketing y,
por último,
herramientas de diagnóstico e
investigación en Neuromarketing.
Si hablábamos de 12 meses y 10 unidades a
mes por unidad,
nos dan un desarrollo temporal de plan de
estudios de 10 meses.
En el onceavo mes presentaremos y
defenderemos nuestro trabajo final de
máster, que además es un trabajo.
Tiene que ser un trabajo práctico,
por lo tanto,
en un perfil como el tuyo podrías
volcarlo incluso algo relacionado con tus
empresas,
con tu empresa y el último mes el doceavo
solo lo utilizarías en el supuesto de que
tengas la necesidad de recuperar hasta un
máximo.
De 3 de esas 10 unidades temáticas que
por el motivo que sea,
pues no se han aprobado en el desarrollo
normal del programa.
En cuanto al primer bloque,
empezaremos viendo en fundamentos para el
neuromarketing como es del marketing al
neuromarketing,
las bases neurocientíficas del
comportamiento del consumidor y luego
como es la psicología del consumidor,
aquí entraremos en el segundo bloque
donde veremos la investigación de
mercados en Neuromarketing,
Neuromarketing Lab,
que es donde vamos a trabajar con todo el
tema de.
El electroenfazo de la Uy, se me bueno,
el late tracking, etcétera, etcétera.
Es decir, el reconocimiento facial,
todas estas herramientas de las cuales
hablábamos antes y justo al acabar esta
unidad temática y antes de continuar con
la siguiente Fernando,
nos encontraríamos en el Ecuador de
nuestro programa formativo, es decir,
justo en la mitad del plan de estudios.
Y es aquí donde de la mano de tu programa
manager académico,
vais a decidir conjuntamente cuál va a
ser tu trabajo final de máster.
¿Quién será el tutor que lo guiará y
empezarás a trabajarlo?
En paralelo al desarrollo de esta última
parte del plan de estudios,
el programa Manager académico es una
figura clave en nuestro ecosistema
formativo.
Es un tutor personalizado que se te
asigna desde el minuto 1 y que no solo te
acompaña,
sino que tiene una vinculación activa en
todo lo que es tu proceso.
Y ahora luego si te explico la
metodología nuestra,
te amplío cómo es esta figura y de qué
manera trabajar a tu lado.
Continuando,
tendríamos métodos y técnicas de medición
en neuromarketing,
pasaríamos al último bloque que son
soluciones empresariales en
neuromarketing,
donde veremos neurobranding, neurodiseño,
neuromarketing aplicado a la experiencia
del cliente y por último, neuroventas.
Con esto cerramos plan de estudios.
Llegamos a ese onceavo mes donde
presentamos y defendemos el trabajo final
de máster, pero además.
Todos nuestros programas tienen varios
bootcamp y certificaciones profesionales
asociadas.
Los bootcamp son formaciones intensivas
de alto rendimiento.
Trabajan en dos líneas con el alumno,
por un lado,
lo que se llaman actividades premaster,
porque se pueden empezar a realizar desde
ya,
y lo que van a trabajar son competencias
que el mercado laboral le exija a
cualquier profesional, es decir,
donde vamos a ver desde.
Cómo crear tu marca personal data,
storytelling, pensamiento creativo,
herramientas de inteligencia artificial,
generativa, cómo manejarlas bien,
etcétera. Y Por otro lado,
otra línea de Boot Camps que lo que van a
hacer es lo que hacen es complementar
académicamente el programa.
En este caso tendremos 1 de ética en
neuromarketing,
otro de inteligencia artificial y
neuromarketing en analítica web y redes
sociales,
neuromarketing aplicado a la experiencia
digital del cliente.
Neuro Management y Neuroliderazgo. Además,
el programa te ofrece la posibilidad de
realizar dos intercambios virtuales con
dos muy prestigiosas instituciones de
Latinoamérica. Por otro lado,
el tecnológico de Monterrey,
considerado a día de hoy la mejor
Universidad de toda Latinoamérica,
y Por otro lado, centrum de Perú,
que es una institución ligada al mundo de
los negocios que también en formato
online figura entre las 5 más importantes
de Latinoamérica, ambos dos intercambios.
Si decides realizarlos,
obtienes una titulación también propia,
una del tecnológico y otra de semtrum.
¿Quieres que te desarrolle cómo sería el
intercambio virtual? O sí,
interesante te lo pues te lo desarrollo
rápidamente.
Nosotros tenemos equivalencia curricular
con los planes de estudios tanto del
tecnológico como de Semtrum. Por tanto,
al comenzar el Máster se te va a ofertar
la posibilidad que una de esas 10
unidades temáticas la puedes realizar
alojada dentro del campus del tecnológico.
Con el profesorado del tecnológico
aprovechando los recursos académicos y
didácticos que ofrece el tecnológico y
relacionándote con el aulario del
tecnológico,
ampliando así el Networking a nivel
internacional.
Igual con centrum y no son obligatorios.
Si decidieras realizarlos,
al finalizar obtienes una titulación del
TEC y otra de centrum muy bien y con esto
cerramos plan de estudios.
Nos quedarían esas actividades premaster
de las cuales te hablaba.
Donde como ves,
tenemos esos cuatro bootcamp que se puede
empezar a realizar desde ahora.
También se pueden realizar mediante y al
finalizar el Máster 1 de marca personal
de manera práctica,
ver cómo diseñarla y construirla y
dotarla de contenido data storytelling,
aprender a manejar esa mundología de
datos para saber darle una narrativa,
técnicas de pensamiento creativo e
innovación e inteligencia artificial
generativa.
Cómo hacer una buena ingeniería de proms
para aquellos alumnos que dominan el
inglés,
estos 3 Boot Camp también se pueden
realizar en inglés.
Desde el minuto 1 Tendrás un taller de
capacitación para nuestro campus virtual.
Nosotros como campus virtual utilizamos
blackboard. No sé, Fernando,
si tienes experiencia en campus virtuales
o has oído hablar de blackboard,
pues mira,
Blackboard está considerado a día de hoy
el mejor campus virtual que existe en El
Mundo. De hecho,
es el mismo que utiliza Harvard,
mejor Universidad del planeta.
Es muy intuitivo y muy amigable,
pero aún así,
desde el minuto 1 se te ofrece un taller
de capacitación.
Para que aprendas a sacarle el máximo
partido posible,
yo ahora si quieres te enseñaré
rápidamente cómo es para que veas.
¿Es súper fácil de manejar, pero bueno,
siempre hay cosas y a dos semanas de
comenzar el máster,
tenemos nuestro programa de desarrollo
profesional aquí durante 14 días y de la
mano de 1 de nuestros docentes
trabajaremos contigo y desarrollaremos
habilidades tales como las comunicativas,
la gestión del tiempo,
de la productividad,
gestión del estrés y qué herramientas de
la inteligencia emocional podemos aplicar
en nuestros?
Entornos empresariales,
tanto este programa como el resto de
bootcamps, si decidieras realizarlos,
obtendrías una titulación también propia,
un certificado de consecución por cada 1
de ellos.
Y digo si decidieras porque es formación
complementaria, es decir,
no es obligatoria,
no tiene cómputo en créditos,
no altera las notas,
tú decides libremente en base a tus
intereses. Si los quieres realizar todos,
5, 1 o ninguno,
tampoco tienen coste extra.
Van todos ellos incluidos dentro de lo
que es la propuesta tanto académica.
Como económica de nuestro máster en
neuromarketing y comportamiento del
consumidor. Muy bien.
¿Con esto cerraríamos la propuesta,
Fernando, Cómo la ves?
¿Tienes alguna duda? No, no, no duda, no,
no, no, para nada, al contrario,
yo creo que al final estáis tocando,
estáis tocando todo lo que es importante,
necesario YYY me interesa porque al final.
Es decir,
el el comportamiento del consumidor es
muy variado y está variando,
no con las nuevas tecnologías.
Entonces todo, todo eso me interesa,
no todo,
todo estar a la como te comentaba,
no estar al día de de Del comportamiento,
no de que en que nos fijamos y en
herramientas de tecnología en y a toc,
toc, toc. O sea,
para mí puedo saber cosas de aquí,
pero para nada, para nada.
¿O sea de rechazar,
o sea alguna cosita sabré no,
pero seguro con la redentoria que tienes
seguro,
pero ya te digo yo que hay mucha otra que
no y que es solo por eso yo siempre digo
que aunque te leas un libro y saques una
buena frase que te sirva para la vida,
ese libro vale la pena, no?
¿Yo creo que tenéis,
tenéis temática muy interesante y bueno,
oye, es, es es verla no? YY listo,
perfecto, pues Fernando siendo así.
¿Te voy a contar cómo es nuestra
metodología de estudio y yo creo que es
importante porque tú has realizado alguno
alguna vez algún curso en online? No,
no vale, pues mira,
para hablar de nuestra metodología te voy
a presentar primero muy rápidamente.
¿Quién es Ob Services School?
Nosotros somos la primera Escuela de
Negocios puramente online en español que
nació en El Mundo y considerada a día de
hoy por todos los grandes rankings como
la mejor Business School en Online
español del planeta.
Ahora luego te enseñaré los rankings para
que veas e incluso te compartiré alguno.
Pero gran parte de este mérito lo tiene
de haber creado y desarrollado una
metodología de estudio propia.
Se llama student non y lo que hace es
colocar al alumno en el centro de
formación de manera activa,
pero siempre acompañado por 3 figuras
clave.
La primera figura clave es la directora
del programa y es más segura que te
compartiré su LinkedIn también para que
lo veas,
aunque te lo voy a enseñar rápidamente,
que ya tiene una trayectoria como docente.
¿Es curioso, Eh? Pero yo la invité.
A ella la invité a hacer lo que pasa,
que no me contestó. Mira,
la la invité recientemente.
¿Yo creo a yo tengo un podcast, Eh?
Yo tengo un podcast.
Y la invité, no,
no creo que porque había una parte del
podcast que quiero.
Quiero invitar a la gente del mundo de la
neurociencia, entre otras cosas,
no científicos, no científicos,
hay médicos, hay YYY. Le contacté sí, sí,
Gema, sí, sí, Gema, sí, sí,
ya ha ganado los últimos 2 años nuestro
el premio como mejor profesora de o b s
de o b s pues pues es raro que no te haya
contestado.
Porque si algo tiene yemas que es muy
accesible a todo,
voy a mirar igual que me equivocara en
algo, pero bueno, es igual.
No te preocupes,
no entretengo ahora con no te preocupes,
pero sí que ella es la ella es la
directora del máster y es la ESA primera
figura de acompañamiento.
La segunda figura de acompañamiento es el
profesor que en ese momento esté en
activo porque su asignatura sea la que se
esté desarrollando,
y la tercera es el programa Manager
académico, ese tutor personalizado,
el que te hablaba antes que se te asigna
desde el minuto 1.
No solo te acompaña si no está vinculado
a todo lo que es tu proceso,
la semana lectiva en o b s da comienzo el
martes de martes a viernes sucede una
única clase en online directo.
La clase siempre sucede a la en la tarde
noche, es decir,
a partir de las 7 19:30 H de la tarde.
Tiene una duración aproximadamente de
1:15 H hora y media es en online directo,
pero en ese mismo momento la grabamos,
así garantizamos que no la vayas a perder
nunca. Si la ves en directo,
Fernando perfecto porque.
Puedes incluso interpelar al profesor con
cualquier tipo de duda que tengas,
y si la ves en diferido,
yo ahora te cuento la ruta para llegar a
él una vez. Dime, no, no, no, no,
entonces es una clase a la semana de 7 a
8,
exactamente una clase a la semana de no
empieza entre las 7 y las 8. ¿Claro,
todos nuestros profesores son
profesionales en activo,
entonces nos adecuamos un poquito ahí,
pero es o de lunes a viernes una única
clase?
¿Normalmente siempre sucede en el entre
martes y miércoles y ahora te cuento por
qué?
Y qué dura hora y media,
aproximadamente la clase vale una vez
finaliza la sesión,
estas 3 figuras de las que te hablaba lo
que van a hacer es extraer aquellas
herramientas y metodologías que se han
estado trabajando durante el aula y
ponerlas a desarrollar bajo supuestos
reales prácticos con el alumno. Es decir,
Fernando, con nosotros no,
no vas a hacer exámenes,
lo que vas a hacer desde el minuto 1 es
enfrentarte a casos reales y actuales de
la profesión.
Que vas a tener que analizar y generar
una estrategia de solución poniendo
siempre en funcionamiento herramientas y
metodologías.
Si hablamos de que el martes se abre la
semana lectiva,
el lunes se cierra como último día para
presentar esos supuestos reales prácticos.
Para probar el máster habrá que superar
entre unos los 7080 casos reales más tu
trabajo final de máster.
Y te pongo un pequeño ejemplo de
acompañamiento por parte del Program
manager.
Para que veas que hablamos de
acompañamiento real,
vamos a suponer que ya estuviéramos
realizando el máster.
Y esta semana la clase fue el martes y
mañana viernes por la mañana.
Tú todavía no te has conectado una sola
vez a tu campus virtual,
esa no suele ser tu dinámica general de
estudio y tu Program manager no tenía
información de que eso iba a suceder.
De ser así, te va a contactar.
Tenemos cuatro vías de comunicación
llamada Telefónica, Whatsapp,
Email y Videollamada.
Te va a contactar porque algo te debe
haber pasado.
Vamos a suponer que lo único que ha
sucedido es que mira,
has tenido una semana con un pico laboral
inesperado y por tanto,
y este dato es muy importante,
te dejas para el fin de semana las cerca
de 8 horas de trabajo semanal,
incluida la clase. Bueno, de ser así,
nosotros lo que vamos a hacer es
monitorizar que tú vayas cumpliendo con
aquellos objetivos y entregas que el
máster te va marcando,
pero también estar estar atentos por si
tuvieras alguna necesidad concreta,
poderte dar soporte y asistirte.
Vamos ahora al otro caso, Mira,
Dios no quiera,
enfermas y momentáneamente no puedes
continuar el ritmo del programa.
No hay problema en el momento en el que
vuelvas a estar bien,
de la misma manera que estamos
comunicándonos tú y yo ahora.
Pero Program manager mediante,
nos reunimos también con el profesor que
esté en activo y redireccionamos la carga
lectiva contigo para que no pierdas ese
ritmo que semanalmente el programa te va
marcando. Además,
todo nuestro profesorado,
como te decía que es profesional en
activo, está a tu disposición.
Mientras dure el programa,
ya no solo para satisfacer dudas
académicas y lectivas,
esto es obvio y evidente,
sino también y muy importante como
consultor profesional gratuito. Es decir,
que si quisiera realizar,
vamos a poner una nueva investigación de
mercado en base a determinados parámetros.
Y antes de ponerla en marcha,
te gustaría validarla con los profesores
de esa materia para ver si realmente va
por buen camino,
aunque sea una cuestión puramente
profesional tuya y empresarial.
Nuestro profesorado te acogerá y te
brindará de manera gratuita una
consultoría para atenderte.
Este es un servicio que nosotros ponemos
a disposición del alumno mientras el
programa está en activo.
Yo con esto cerraría la parte de
metodología,
a no ser que tengas alguna pregunta
concreta que no haya sabido. No, no, no,
no, ninguna,
porque al final es la metodología de una
Universidad privada,
Uniese un Harvard no que es hoy en día es
funciona por casos,
al final es lo que hay que hacer en la
vida, no es.
¿No hay mejor examen que darle a la
cabeza cuando tienes ahí un caso raro,
claro,
cuando tienes un problema que lo tienes
que solucionar realmente más que tener un
examen de lente dónde memorizo? Exacto,
memorizo y luego acabo aplicando todo lo
que he aprendido y encajaría nuestra
metodología. Entiendo lo que vas buscando,
Fernando, bueno, perfecto, pues mira,
te voy a enseñar rápidamente nuestro
campus virtual para que veas que es muy
sencillo y sobre todo porque hay una
parte de él que.
Y quisiera enseñarte,
el que vas a ver es el mío y yo,
aunque ahora empiezo también un máster de
nuevo, no lo tengo cargado todavía,
pero bueno, vas a ver que es muy,
muy fácil y muy intuitivo.
Cuando entramos tú das clase en este,
en el de no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
yo he dado clases anteriormente,
ahora solo hago ya asesoramiento de de
alumnos y ayudo a mis compañeros a.
A a a saber cómo hacerlo con los alumnos
cuando llegan.
Ya son años aquí en la escuela y muchos
años dentro del sector educativo YY
empiezo ahora otro máster como alumno
porque me encanta. Me encanta estudiar.
O sea,
yo tengo un cerebro que necesita
estímulos. Si no se aburre, pues mira,
esto es nuestro campus virtual.
Cuando entras siempre lo primero Fernando
que vas a encontrar son aquellas noticias
que de manera transversal.
Tienen incidencia en todos nuestros
programas. Ahora,
por ejemplo nuestro programa de Mentoría
donde tenemos alumnos experimentados y
luego te enseñaré a 1 de ellos que está
aquí en Barcelona,
que lo que hacen es daros la mano e
introduciros a los nuevos dentro de
nuestro ecosistema formativo.
O también un premio al emprendimiento
donde hemos estado recogiendo propuestas
hasta junio y este 30 de septiembre.
Bueno,
las cuatro mejores se han estado
mentorizando de manera individual.
Y las y a la mejor diseñada le
otorgaremos un premio de €6000 y que se
revelará ahora el 30 de octubre. Bueno,
la documentación necesaria para la doble
titulación y también cómo encontrar tu
ruta de grabaciones, es decir,
aquellas grabaciones que ya están,
aquellas clases ya están grabadas.
¿Cómo acceder a ellas para poder no
perder la ruta?
Una vez pasamos las noticias tendríamos
nuestro tenemos una masterclass de gemini.
Para estudiantes el 23 de septiembre,
es decir,
tenemos implementado el lo que es la
inteligencia artificial de Google dentro
de nuestro campus para que os ayude
también y luego ya tendrías el acceso
directo a tus asignaturas.
Yo en este caso ahora tengo los boot Camp,
como veis el de personal, branding, data,
storytelling, etcétera.
Ya aquí el acceso al aula virtual,
al flujo de actividades,
al buzón de sugerencias y a un centro de
respuestas interactivo. 247.
Esto que vemos es el campus.
Porque el aula está separada y está
separada precisamente para no interferir
1 con otro. Es decir,
es como ir a la Universidad,
ir allí dependiendo de tu clase,
ir a tu aula.
Aquí tendrías el flujo de actividades,
que es la ordenación por prioridad de
todas tus actividades,
desde entregas de trabajo, clases,
webinars, boot Camp,
Workshops pero organizados,
foros de debate o de discusión o de
investigación organizados por prioridad
acceso a todos tus cursos.
Calendario cronológico del aula,
calificaciones de tus asignaturas y por
último,
herramientas informáticas necesarias para
el desempeño óptimo del programa de
vuelta al campus.
¿Nos encontraríamos ya con clases
próximas? Como ves,
yo no tengo ninguna programada y en
grabaciones aparecerían los buscan que se
están cargando, pero bueno,
como ves bueno sale ahora que no hay
ninguno, pero deberían de estar,
los buscan.
Calendario del campus secretaria,
con la documentación de la información
adicional y el acceso a todo el equipo de
la Universidad. Y hablamos de todo,
desde decana y vicedecana,
servicio al estudiante a todos los
programas Manager.
Recuerda que 1 de ellos se te asignará
secretaria académica. Diplomas,
documentación responsable internacional
de comunidad alumna,
aunque ahora te enseñaré a nuestro
responsable,
nuestro Presidente aquí en España,
Administración soporte técnico y Raquel,
que es la directora de nuestro
departamento de carreras.
Importante porque este departamento.
Tendrás acceso a él de manera gratuita y
limitada y de por vida.
Y aquí vas a encontrar desde esta ruta al
emprendimiento que tenemos,
la cual incluye nuestra incubadora VS.
Donde trabajamos contigo las 27 fases de
la emprendeduría,
desde la introducción a un ecosistema
empresarial hasta la ir a la financiación,
nuestro premio al emprendimiento,
un ciclo sobre el empleo oculto de
trabajo.
Ahora tienes workshops de motivación y
gestión de equipos,
también de reinvención profesional.
Bolsos del liderazgo todos los meses,
una masterclass enfocada en directo,
ahora en septiembre, talento y propósito,
haz que tú genialidad impacte en El Mundo.
Bolsos de oratoria,
realizamos un diagnóstico exclusivo y
gratuito de tu perfil profesional para
que sea visible y atractivo,
pues a clientes, socios, headhunter,
reclutadores, es decir,
dependiendo de hacia dónde la quieras
llevar,
un portal de empleo propio con ofertas a
nivel internacional.
Una acceso también al portal de empleo de
Business Graduate.
Ponemos a tu disposición cuatro sesiones
individuales con 1 nuestros coach,
que te ayudará a diseñar un plan de
acción ajustado a tus objetivos,
pero también con 1 de nuestros mentores,
que también en cuatro sesiones trabaja
contigo. Pues si quieres trabajar con él,
una
De negocio o cualquier cosa a nivel
empresarial, la bolsa de talento.
Un ciclo de emprendimiento,
otro de empleabilidad. Como ves,
todos estos complementos de desarrollo
profesional están a tu disposición,
que se van renovando cada poco tiempo.
Estarán a disposición de manera gratuita,
ilimitada y de por vida.
Por ser parte de nuestra Comunidad.
En el siguiente apartado tendríamos las
bibliotecas en la nuestra.
Todos nuestros docentes alojarán ahí el
material académico necesario para que
afrontes con garantía de éxito el máster.
Pero también tendrás acceso a la de EPSCO,
a la de El libro y a la de Harvard Deusto.
Y por último,
esto aquí por vida también es de por vida.
¿Esto no?
Las bibliotecas también son de por vida y
luego aquí encontrarás aquellas noticias
que nuestra comunidad alumni va
organizando tanto a nivel internacional
como nacional, desde el Directorio Alumni,
nuestro Side Alumni,
donde Entrarás tendrás el acceso a todos
ellos.
Los alumni Days, los club de Alumni,
el programa de Mentoría que hablábamos
antes, la alumni Welcome experience,
la alumni madting, los after words, mira,
nuestra comunidad alumni está integrada
por los más de 42000 profesionales que
desde el año 2005, 2006.
Como te decía antes,
nosotros somos pioneros en formación
superior online en El Mundo en español se
ha formado con nosotros y tiene un doble
compromiso contigo, vital, gratuito.
¿Qué es?
Por un lado,
ese desarrollo profesional a través de
todos esos programas que hemos estado
viendo una vez finalice el máster.
Por otro lado,
el Networking para hacer networking.
Organizamos nuestra comunidad alumni en 9
clubs,
1 internacional que es el de Valeria y
los otros 8 tienen que ver con aquellos
países donde hay un número importante de
alumnos.
Evidentemente España es nuestra gran
comunidad, donde tenemos a Ricard Muñoz.
Él es Mediating Manager en el Fútbol Club
Barcelona,
donde tiene una trayectoria de más de 22
años, si no me equivoco.
Es coaching, coach Ejecutivo,
trabaja en Recursos Humanos y gestión del
talento y este the speaker, además,
también fue seleccionador nacional
absoluto de hockey sobre patines.
A nivel femenino,
cuál es la labor de mira 23 años en el
Fútbol Club Barcelona.
¿Cuál es la labor de Ricard? Pues bien,
además de organizar de manera presencial
aquí en Barcelona,
pues esos alumni after world, Alumni Days,
Alumni meetings, alumni Welcome,
la de interconectaros a vosotros,
dependiendo de con quién de nuestra
Comunidad de alumnos.
Puedes establecer sinergias colaborativas,
reales, es decir,
que solo para hacer networking no solo
vas a tener site alumni con el contacto,
sino que Ricard pueda ayudarte a que ese
contacto sea mucho más directo y
favorable. Yo no quiero enseñarte. Bueno,
tengo programados 3 perfiles,
1 es el de Elías,
que él está en nuestro programa de
Mentoría.
Él ha realizado dos másteres con nosotros.
El último fue el de Coaching.
Como ves superactivo en nuestras redes y
en nuestros programas.
Él es 1 de nuestros mentores.
El tuvo una trayectoria en la empresa
Oracle de comunicación de más de 27 años,
donde acabó siendo en su última etapa
manager desarrollador de negocio para la
zona de mea. Salió en febrero del 23,
que fue justo cuando empezó el máster
porque pasó a ser 1 de los directivos del
centro tecnológico de Cataluña,
pero además es mentor.
En aticolab y también en starsand,
que es una incubadora de startups
norteamericana cuya sede europea está
aquí en Reus o Sonia Zazo,
que ella sí que realizó este máster y
ella trabaja en publicis,
que es una de las 5 multinacionales de
publicidad más importantes que existen y
cuya sede en Madrid.
Ella dirige toda la parte que tiene que
ver con marcas de lujo.
Ella ha trabajado mucho en partes de en
medios, tanto en Spark como en Optimedia.
Y importante porque yo creo que esto nos
revaloriza mucho. Eva Olmedo casas,
ella es alumna nuestra,
es docente de neuromarketing,
pero en en e a e Business School,
que supongo que conocerás una Business
School a nivel presencial muy importante
aquí en aquí en Barcelona,
pero para ser docente en euromarketing se
títuló con nosotros y esto el el máster
con nosotros como puedes ver,
y es docente no solo en.
Primer grado de administración también es
certificado profesional. Es decir,
y más allá de Enseñarte yo perfiles,
te invito a que vengas a nuestra página
de LinkedIn.
Aquí si le das a antiguos alumnos,
Fernando,
te aparecen los más de 17500 perfiles que
en todo El Mundo tiene registrado dese
formado con nosotros. Como veis,
España es la gran comunidad y si le vamos
a España nos aparecerán más de 3400.
Podemos hacer búsqueda incluso si quieres
por neuromarketing, perdón.
¿No marketing para ver,
pues quiénes parecen 48 especialistas
para que puedas ver? Bueno,
pues quiénes son, qué hacen,
qué se dedican, etcétera, etcétera.
Muy bien. Yo con esto cerraría.
Creo que prácticamente todo lo que es la
propuesta. Fernando está clara, dudas,
ninguna.
¿Y encajaría lo que vas buscando? ¿Sí, sí,
total, en todos los aspectos, sí,
en todos los aspectos me parece que lo es,
es es una muy buena manera de cómo lo lo
estáis enfocando, sabes? Nada, ningún,
ningún comentario.
Ser pioneros en formación superior online
en El Mundo.
Yo esto le sabe muy mal a mi jefe que lo
diga, pero es la realidad,
significa haber sido los primeros en
llegar y los primeros en equivocarte y
eso es muy valioso porque sabes que no te
funciona.
Que no te funciona como tú antes decías.
Me doy cuenta que no tengo que invertir
ya tanto en interiorismo no es necesario,
pues a nosotros igual sabemos que hace
falta un tutor personalizado,
que el campus tiene que ser muy intuitivo,
muy amigable, que todo lo tengas dentro,
que el aula esté separada, etcétera,
etcétera. Está muy bien,
está muy bien YYYY el y el y el talante,
no los los profesionales,
todos los alumnos que pasan,
pues al final no es solo el máster,
sino el entorno,
no el ecosistema que habéis creado,
que creo que eso tiene mucho valor.
Perfecto, pues Fernando.
Ya lo último que entonces que me quedaría
por enseñarte es como es un proceso de
admisión con nosotros.
Nosotros no tenemos matriculación abierta,
aunque seamos una formación online,
tenemos un número muy limitado de plazas,
no entran más de 45 alumnos por
convocatoria porque sino no podríamos
garantizar que tengas el Program manager
y todo lo que hemos estado viendo.
Por lo tanto,
cuando alguien quiere ser un alumno
nuestro,
tiene que aplicar a través de un comité
de admisiones para aplicar al Comité de
Admisiones.
Te pediré 3 documentos muy sencillos
tuyos, bueno,
básica en tu con un perfil empresarial
como el tuyo, dos básicamente,
que serían tu currículo actualizado o
perfil de LinkedIn y tu documento de
identidad.
¿Si tuvieras también una fotografía de tu
título universitario también me valdría
que me dijiste que eran turismo, verdad?
Sí, perfecto en el IESY tal,
pero a nivel universitario no sería el
universitario el que buscaríamos el.
Con estos 3 documentos yo aplicaría 1/4,
que es un informe en base a lo que hemos
estado hablando y defendería que una de
las últimas cuatro plazas que nos quedan
fueran para ti.
Nosotros tenemos Comité de admisiones.
En realidad lo tendríamos que haber
tenido el jueves de hoy,
pero lo tendremos mañana y el lunes.
Este último Comité de admisiones.
Creemos lo que sí que trae de bueno es
poder solicitar ayudas económicas.
Las dos líneas más importantes que da la
escuela,
que son cierre de convocatoria y últimas
plazas,
últimas plazas solo se otorgan no se
otorgan a las cuatro,
sino que se puede otorgar 1, 2, 3 o 4,
dependiendo del perfil Fernando.
¿Entiendo que esta formación la llevarías
a través de créditos Fundae o es algo que
Harías tú directamente a través de la
empresa? No lo no lo he pensado,
o sea si te digo la verdad y como solo te
falta decirme el coste.
Vale, pues no, no, no,
no he mirado la la manera de
materializarlo, la verdad. Vale,
no te lo digo porque si lo quisieras
hacer por fundad,
porque teniendo 30 tiendas entiendo que
tendrás un volumen mínimo 30 trabajadores,
no, no, lo sí tengo 30 empleados, o sea,
te voy a explicar un poco la estructura,
yo tengo dos sociedades,
no de las cuales sobre la principal,
pues tengo 5 tiendas, no 33 tiendas más.
Ahora tendré cuatro más,
pero abiertas 3 y de ahí caen 18
franquicias, entonces ahí no, no,
no vamos a poder, no vamos a poder,
pero sí sobre las tiendas propias,
que sumando las dos sociedades y que en
estos momentos tengo 32,
me parece empleados. Sí,
los créditos fundáis,
si no los has utilizado sabes que caducan
al año, es decir, lo que tienes en 2025.
Cuando llega a 2026,
si no lo has gastado lo pierdes.
El máster,
al al suceder entre 2025 y 2026,
puedes utilizar créditos de 1 año y del
otro y créditos te dan a partir de creo
que son 5 trabajadores,
a partir de 5 trabajadores tienes entre
400 €500 y a partir de ahí es muy fácil.
No, no los has usado, los gestionáis,
esto sí,
yo tengo una persona que me lo me lo
podría gestionar. Sí, nosotros tenemos un,
tenemos un departamento que lo gestiona,
lo único es que tiene un pequeño coste,
creo que son 80 o €90, pero te lo hacen.
Te pediríamos una información que es
nombre de la empresa CIF, el la dirección,
la persona responsable, sí,
vas a ser tú o otra persona con la que
habláramos y a partir de ahí se cruzan
documentación YY se mira que tienes para
cubrirlo todo perfecto,
que solo cubres una parte. Yo creo, bueno,
y lo que te decía lo puedes hacer.
Al ser el Master 2025 y 2026,
puedes hacer una parte en 2025 y el resto
en 2026.
¿Vale, claro,
entonces ahí se puede combinar bastante
bien YY sabes si se pueden combinar las
dos sociedades que tengo bajo la misma
marca? No creo que no,
creo que solo permiten una, unas,
una única, creo, eh,
pero ahí me pillas porque tanto tanto no
conozco.
Conozco el funcionamiento de fundae a
grandes rasgos, pero hay una,
hay una página web donde ellos te
explican todo y te contestan al momento,
casi al momento de cualquier duda para
ser una institución pública.
Bastante rápido en Fundoa Eh me meto
enfundae.
es yo si quieres te la comparto ahora por
Whatsapp para que la tengas no te
preocupes no, si ya ya he apuntado listo,
perfecto,
pues Fernando viste el valor oficial del
programa en nuestra página web, no, no,
pues te lo voy a compartir,
te comparto de nuevo pantalla y te lo
enseño para que lo podamos ver 1 segundo,
a ver, Ay, no, no, ay, aquí no tengo,
mira.
El programa tiene un valor sin ayudas y
es único pago de por vida para todo lo
que estábamos hablando de €7500 vale,
ahora si aplicáramos en este último
comité y en tu caso yo creo que tu perfil
encajaría muy bien,
podríamos solicitar una ayuda del 15% más
otra del 5.
Esto lleva el programa de 7500 a 6056,30.
Aquí como ves hay un tercer factor que
entraría en juegos,
que si fueras a fundar sería así seguro.
¿Que sería la modalidad de pago?
Al realizar un pago al contado,
la escuela te ofrece una ayuda especial
del 10% más.
Entonces el programa pasaría de 7500 a
5450,60. Vale, vale,
y si lo fundai aquí no aparece,
lo no lo veo. Lo de Fundai no, no, no,
no fundai.
Lo que fundae como funciona es de la
siguiente manera,
nosotros tenemos que cruzar una
documentación y unas facturas,
vosotros tenéis que pagar el máster.
O sea,
tu empresa paga el máster y lo que hace
funda él.
Luego es exactamente te lo va descontando
la Seguridad Social.
Si te cubre la la cuantía total te va,
te va quitando cuotas de la Seguridad
Social hasta que llegues a los 5450
perfecto.
Y sí que pide que esté pagado factura YY
orden de transferencia para que la gente
no haga chanchullos.
Claro que vivimos en un país donde a la
que te descuidas.
¿Alguien ha inventado algo?
¿Vale, aquí lo que hay que ver es bueno,
ya eso ya lo miraría con tu equipo o con
la persona que me igual me puede ayudar a
mí con el tema de fundae es es valorar no
con la con la empresa que tengo,
pues cuánto cuánto se puede obtener?
¿Claro,
cuántos trabajadores tienes en esa
empresa? Ay, pues mira, te lo digo en 1,
segundo, un momentito, un segundín.
Aquí aquí espera porque es el 31313.
¿Tienes créditos?
Yo creo que suficientes para partiéndolo
entre este año y el que viene y más si no
has utilizado nada. Fernando todavía.
No, no he utilizado nada 31, pero sí sí,
más o menos sí,
pues es algo que te merece la pena porque
ya te digo,
llegaremos a 2026 y volver a contador a
cero y entonces te recalcularán los
créditos en base a las contrataciones de
este año. Vale,
o sea que si tienes vamos a poner que
tienes €3500 este año puedes pagar la
parte proporcional del máster ahora y el
año que viene vuelves a tener 3500,
pero si no los gastamos de este año.
¿No se te acumulan para el año que viene,
o sea, yo ahora pagaría 3500 en efectivo,
no?
Y los otros 3000 el año que viene o todo
de golpe,
no lo sé ahí eso ahí sí que me pillas,
pero yo creo que al llevarlo a 2 años se
paga una parte proporcional ahora y en
enero la otra parte creo, pero yo,
yo a vosotros, yo a vosotros creo,
creo que se hace así o no lo sé,
eso te lo tengo que preguntar al
departamento cómo lo cómo lo dicen,
yo te lo miro.
El resumen es que me interesa y quiero
hacerlo. Vale, luego ya si tú me dices,
oye, mañana se presenta todo esto,
te mando toda la información estatal,
claro, mándamelo cuanto antes, claro,
mándamelo cuanto antes. Sí, claro,
es que estamos cerrando para empezar
porque empezamos la semana de o sea,
la la segunda semana de octubre.
¿Que será martes 7? Si no me equivoco no,
pero te lo digo,
tenéis mañana reunión de Del Comité, Sí,
sí, comité, mañana comité, mañana,
claro información,
ahora necesito información cuanto antes y
yo mañana lo presentaríamos que sale
hacia delante.
Lo único que te voy a solicitar ahí son
los datos de la empresa para llevarlo a
fundae y ya la semana que viene se pone
en contacto contigo la persona encargada
nuestra y te dice qué necesita,
que no necesita y de qué manera.
Vale, yo te voy a enviar todo,
te envío mi currículum,
me envió el DNIY si fotografía vale
envíamelo también vale, perfecto,
pues Fernando,
cuyo con eso lo preparo y yo mañana
presentaría en la mañana por lo tanto a
yo creo que a mediodía tipo una 1:30 h,
tendríamos contestación en el caso de ser
favorable.
Sí que te pediré que nos podamos conectar
10 minutitos horas por videollamada,
porque te enseñaré el campus bien,
entrarás en tu campus de alumno ya y te
lo enseñaré todo y haremos la última
parte, lo haremos conjuntamente.
Vale, perfecto,
me envías por Whatsapp Tu mail y sí,
te lo envío todo, todo en media horita,
una horita perfecto. Pues quedamos así,
Fernando, oye,
pues ha sido un placer y muy agradable la
conversación de verdad, no, hombre, no,
o sea, has hablado tú y yo no, no, no, no,
y tú también al principio yo nada más, Eh,
hoy un placer igualmente Fernando,
quedamos así hasta ahora, gracias.